[Musik]
ich fand es auch richtig dass die
kanzlerin heute weniger belehrend als
erklärend gesprochen hat ist ja ganz
wichtig dass hier noch einmal
ausdrücklich um verständnis für diese
restriktiven maßnahmen geworben hat
gewusst was sie kennen die kanzlerin
lange wie haben sie diese audio
pressekonferenz wahrgenommen da gab es
ja auch ziemliche probleme das hat alles
nicht so richtig funktioniert fehlt
eigentlich momentan so die tägliche live
ansprache oder auch video ansprache der
kanzlerin an die deutschen
und wir tun hat mich ein bisschen
erinnert an die erste mondlandung die
müsste dann konzern 68 69 gewesen seien
viel schlechter heute tot damals auch
nicht also das hat mich schon etwas
gewundert ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
eine öffentliche erklärung der kanzlerin
tag für tag richtig wäre denn sowas
würde sich auch abnutzen sollte schon
einen besonderen anlass geben wenn sich
die kanzlerin in dieser form an die
ganze bevölkerung gewendet herr gabriel
wie sehen sie das sie saßen lange im
kabinett neben der kanzlerin
wie bewerten sie das wie sie momentan
kommuniziert also erstmal glaube ich das
wort kam postfach recht ich habe vor
wenigen tagen mit freunden darüber
gestritten wie häufig angela merkel in
der öffentlichkeit auftreten soll da gab
es auch leute die gesagt haben sie muss
doch eigentlich viel stärker
kommunizieren ständig präsent sein sagt
naja
ich hätte eher die sorge dass sich das
abnutzt
und am ende das kein ereignis mehr es
wenn die kanzlerin was sagt und ich
finde da wolfgang bosbach eben das
richtige gespür für gehabt in der sache
selber bin ich froh dass an der spitze
der regierung jemand ist der
krisenerprobt ist sie hat wahrscheinlich
nicht zu ihrer freude aber es war halt
so sie hat in der zeit in der sie
kanzlerin war enorm viele krisen
durchstehen müssen ich denke die zeit 2
13 bis 17
das ging los kaum wollen wir in die
regierung gewählt besetzte russland die
grimm und der ukraine konflikt begann
kaum war das einigermaßen eingedämmt
ging's mit der griechenland-krise los
die buk sich aus zu euro-krise und am
ende kann man auch die flüchtlingskrise
dazu wir haben jemand an der spitze der
regierung
die jedenfalls krisenerprobt ist und ich
glaube das ist gut fürs land aber muss
bereits angesprochen nicht einmal die
übertragung hat richtig funktioniert er
vergleicht es mit der übertragung der
der mondlandung ist es ein schwieriges
zeichen wenn das selbst das in
deutschland nicht funktioniert eine
vernünftige audio pressekonferenz mit
der kanzlerin
also möchte ich keine wertung abgeben
das wird sigmar gabriel auch nicht
wissen woran es letztendlich gelegen hat
aber ich bin ganz sicher beim nächsten
mal wird es diese probleme nicht mehr
geben vergabe steht happens
[Musik]